Miserable, How to Fail at Life
Written and narrated by The Reverse Maven
An unabridged audiobook
Copyright 2025 All rights reserved
Introduction
Welcome to Miserable, How to Fail at Life, the definitive guide to optimizing your existence for maximum despair.
I am The Reverse Maven, your chief pessimism officer, and I have spent years perfecting the art of failure so you don't have to stumble into success by accident.
This audiobook contains 174 pages of meticulously researched techniques for dismantling hope, sabotaging relationships, and cultivating a sustainable baseline of existential dread.
Unlike traditional self-help books that promise transformation, this book delivers on a simpler promise, consistency, consistent, reliable, predictable misery.
Because if you're going to be miserable, you might as well be good at it.
The book is organized into 11 parts, each focusing on a different domain of human suffering,
from the physical foundations of malaise, to the psychological architecture of despair, to the social mechanics of isolation.
Think of this as a cookbook, but instead of recipes for dinner, these are recipes for disaster.
Each chapter includes specific ingredients, step-by-step instructions, and the expected yield of your efforts.
Whether it's 24 hours of foggy resentment or a lifetime of regret, we've calibrated each technique for maximum impact.
A note on tone, this book is satirical.
It is a mirror held up to the self-help industrial complex, reflecting back the absurdity of optimization culture taken to its logical extreme.
If you find yourself actually following these instructions, please stop, put down the book, and call someone who cares about you.
For everyone else, let's begin the audit.
Part 1. The Kitchen. Foundations.
Part 1. The Kitchen.